hi this is zachariah porter and this is
under the influencer
[Music]
i do a lot of different kinds of videos
on my tic toc but one of my most popular
videos are my
vintage or old school food machines oh
my freaking got a bloomin on your
machine six frickin dolls of get it and
i think a lot of people think that i
just come across these like really
coincidentally but actually those days
when i film those it's a full production
day where i'm driving sometimes up to
like 120 miles to these like perfect
locations that i know have these kind of
machines and some days are complete
misses but i love that on the final
product of the video it always looks
like oh he kind of just came across that
when in reality i am like scouring so
many thrift stores for the perfect item
you gotta be freaking kidding me it's a
popcorn machine that looks like a little
trolley recently um i did a video with a
popcorn machine and that one was one of
the hardest ones to find i remember
driving from my apartment all the way
like 90 miles past my house to this
thrift store that was great but they
didn't have the right machine i only
found an ice cream machine it wasn't
cool enough it has to be interesting and
then i went to the middle of
massachusetts still confined to another
thrift store and then went all the way
to rhode island north of providence and
that's where i found this beautiful
popcorn machine so i think i was on the
road for four and a half hours that day
but i was listening to a motivational
podcast and i was feeling very empowered
and inspired to keep going which in turn
i got that awesome platform machine
you